leave off with the last girl so front
front foot nectarine two dhoklas
vectoring back to front of drugs except
drink box with a drink protection
okay that's fine he's just a a stressed
or that's all he is
he's conditioning I'm not trying to get
him off balance by doing stuff like this
you've got same force
you're moving that forward stand for
Singh he's grounded me ground that's
this drill don't try to take weight off
with it right now just do the drill
okay try so you went to the group he's
gonna go to the elbow and I'm gonna take
that to the other foot and then I do the
same drill one drill two onto the elbow
and then drill three go one two three
okay here and I'm gonna bring him to my
shoulder I bring him to my shoulder my
shoulder
boom I'm bringing in he's trying to get
there but I'm bringing him there - same
thing on the elbow I don't make it his
job to hit my elbow I bring his down to
my wall and I'm here I popped it to my
shoulders
okay okay so yesterday we were we were
here here here and then we had them find
this one okay and again that was tough
because that's where your shikaku is but
it's a good one because if you were
vectoring you don't have that shikaku
because I don't have a equal distributed
status okay so same thing I'm gonna
bring them in and you've got to train me
you see and then I do this okay
so as I'm this is bringing his body you
see that okay so but it's not me pulling
him
I'm vectoring then vectoring to the
other one boom he hits the back foot and
then if I do it wrong of course
okay so one he comes in oh and he gets
that ground back so same thing he's
pushing right if I if I don't have that
single point then I'll generate a
shikaku diss angle where he's pushing
you see oh yeah okay and then also I
can't go back if I have this Chicago I
can't go back is that it starts to take
me off the bow starts to push me into
this country
but if I have the ground vector then
you got it so make sure you're not here
and you're going racing angle a little
enforcing okay
it's here Oh on that I feel that and
then I move it just like the other drill
okay
so here there's the Yong Yong clash okay
that Yong Yong clash is where his body
was organized to do it in other words if
he leave your amount of gear and get
your feet see he's not organized at that
point okay
so what I'm going to do is the first the
Jiu Jitsu tactic which is healed to that
okay now he's not as organized do you
understand and then so I disorganize him
I don't contest this and I take that
energy onto my life so he's going to
come in and it's organized it should hit
it and I yield to it so now when I do it
it's the same mechanics but he doesn't
have all the balance that he might have
had before
okay but mine now timing has to be
brought into it so he's in you
feel in your movement can get smaller
you don't have to do a big weight shift
you just have to do the first deal or
Zorba thankless trunk so these these
drills are just drills in their
incremental paint these you're
developing skill sets so the first
reconciliation is with the weight shift
that's that's where I do the movie so
our front foot vectoring I'm on the
front foot and then I bring that here
when and the perfect timing I can't go
ahead and hit it needs to be organized
here and I can't relate because that's
the other drills okay so it's just a
timing um make him go past where he
wants it's there okay how do you do that
right right when I'm feeling just like
the weapons I feel that young
I keep easing off that's the end
reconciliation I feel too young and I
ease it off reach out for them let him
home and then I do the robot
okay this that's the last row
that's the last row now to do that you
had to relax in order to move it from
one to the other
you see if you keep this tension you
can't move you have to relax and you can
move do you understand
and that's actually what is more
important so this is yes we do weight
shifting all the time but if I weight
shift with tension then I'm probably
going to be young and get overridden
here okay so it's more that I have go
ahead I just have the this release I
have to release didn't give me some
energy I just release it and it's enough
without any of the other stuff okay so
he hits the wall boom hits that release
so I'm not here not here it's just very
relaxed long release and he'll hit the
ground this is energies coming down okay
so that's been this next drill and the
last one I had a tiny draw and then I
went to and this one I let him hit the
ground I let it all go to the ground he
comes in and it is whoa that's it Oh
relax incoming harder that's all okay
I'm going to show you why that stillness
important because when I do a hand
change for example it's not yielding
like this okay so it is yielding in
terms of it went into his but it's not
with no integrity it's not me getting
out of the way okay so here it is
yielding okay let it go and then he can
push on it and you see it's capable of
always doing the same thing okay so
there's some structural integrity to the
pattern that I want to generate there's
no GUI Center it's not it's not ever any
different from the first drill
he's always round back dream I'm always
Brown vectoring whatever I have so it's
yielding but it's never it's never of
GUI but it's soft you see this is soft
tip of gooey soft there's holes in the
center
[Music]
it's not gonna be in here it keeps the
integrity going and I'm a community then
I find his head and now I'm projecting
his head I'm not taking him off that
inspired by pulling his you know like
he's bending the bends on me and then I
take this line and drive me outside his
basis of course it's the same projection
so just like this is the same subjection
and this is the same projection this now
becomes the same projection won't right
there
the exact projection just it's EDP not
yet when it's still the ground vectoring
so yeah they're not yeah just using this
here I would do this grip in my wrist
here I was using this contact
this is that same young young contention
point don't go like this I don't want to
yield here because if that's a weapon in
there I don't want to go here okay what
I'm going to do is deconstruct the young
young but moving his head here now out
of his arms going right in the direction
that I want it's not pressing on me here
so I start a circle do you see it it's
very small and then I go here now that's
not really lifting on me this way and I
find the next young football writer
so make sure you dismantle all so again
here push push
it's not you can't ever do it wrong
don't go here to free the technique here
use that Yong Yong deconstructed here
[Music]
don't go here yeah he's got his balance
if you doing all this drive you're gonna
get the Kazushi pattern right I'm gonna
tilt his head DC then send the hip over
do you remember like this guy standing
straight up